today we discuss the real rigging of the
election the media sacrificing its
credibility to attack donald trump
whether the woke will rule the roost if
joe biden takes office and kovid doesn't
care about your politics i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now
at expressvpn.com ben we'll get to all
the news
in just one moment first let me remind
you that if you are a responsible human
being you should stop whatever you're
doing right now and get some life
insurance if you have dependents people
who depend on you for your income it's
gonna be bad enough god forbid something
happens to you but then if they have to
bear the expense of you no longer being
able to provide that's gonna be even
worse you need life insurance but
how the hell are you gonna get life
insurance where do you even shop for it
ah i'm glad you asked the answer
is policygenius.com policy genius makes
it really easy they combine
a cutting-edge insurance marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
you time and money
right now you could say 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really do start to add up here's
how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape the best
part they work for you not the insurance
company so if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they'll take care of everything for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
1600 reviews on trustpilot and google
which is
a pretty high rating so if you need life
insurance
and if you're a responsible person you
do head on over to policygenius.com
right now to get started you could say
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and very very important
to get it right okay so the media
narrative the democratic narrative
continues a pace
until the moment donald trump declares
that joe biden is president-elect of the
united states we are on the precipice
on the precipice of disaster of doom
millions will die i know we were all
killed by climate change
and i know that we were all killed also
by net neutrality uh we were killed by
pretty much everything that trump ever
did
but the good news is that like a cat we
have nine lives and we're back
only to be killed again by president
trump's failure to say that joe biden is
president-elect yet even though not a
single state has yet certified his vote
and also none of the electors have
actually voted now i've heard some
rumors today about republicans talking
about
republican state legislators just
certifying slates of electors
who are republican and would vote for
trump okay you can't do that in
contravention to whatever evidence there
is available
if you're in michigan and biden ends up
winning the actual vote count by 140 000
and you have some sporadic claims or
even many claims of individual voter
fraud that is not enough to overcome the
presumption of proof
that is required for 140 000 vote lead
in michigan for biden to be overturned
by another slate of electors so how
about we
don't talk about silly things that is
not going to happen and virtually no one
is calling for that to happen because of
course that would
be on the verge of breaking democracy
now we'll point out here
there were democrats who called for that
with hillary clinton in 2016. right so
it is not unprecedented
for people to say it but it's dumb no
matter who is saying it okay with that
said
the willingness of the media and
democrats to go along with the narrative
that we are on the precipice
as i said yesterday this has very little
to do with reality and very much to do
with the entire narrative the media have
set up for themselves so the media
decided the democrats decided
that they had to take down donald trump
at any cost and that meant
bending breaking the rules meant
politicizing the intelligence agencies
it meant turning journalistic outlets
into open activist outlets it meant
reporting rumors instead of facts it
meant drawing
narrative conclusions from insufficient
facts all of that was justified because
of course donald trump was not just
orange man bad
he was incipient hitler well now as it
turns out donald trump may have lost the
2020 election
if he is found to have lost the election
if the electors vote and he is no longer
president
he will leave peacefully if you think
that donald trump is going to stick
around and get violent or something
he's going to thrash and you're going to
drag him out in handcuffs that's leftist
fantasy thinking it is not going to
happen but
here's the thing the left requires the
fantasy because if it turns out that
donald trump
was you know he bloviated a lot and he
did a lot of unconventional things as
president but he really didn't threaten
the system
and he's not really threatening the
system now it turns out that all of the
sacrifices they made to
their own credibility all of their
institutional
collapse in pursuit of donald trump was
not justified it turns out that they
sacrificed themselves on the altar of
donald trump for nothing because it
turns out he was never the kind of
threat
they determined him to be and they can't
have that so they're just going to
continue to portray him
as that kind of a threat there's a
famous scene in a man for all seasons
i've quoted this before but it is really
one of my favorite scenes in all of
theater
uh and all of movies it's a great film
everybody should watch it
uh in which it's about sir thomas moore
and henry viii
and sir thomas moore of course refuses
to acknowledge that henry viii has the
capacity to divorce
to divorce his wife in order to marry
anne boleyn and there's a scene
where sir thomas more is talking to his
son-in-law roper
about sir richard rich who's this guy
who used to work for thomas more and now
is going to testify against moore
that moore actually doesn't believe that
the divorce is okay
and that the new marriage is okay and
this will get more executed so richard
rich comes and he threatens
thomas more and roper turns to thomas
more and he says you should arrest that
man
and thomas moore says there's no law he
hasn't broken any law i can't arrest him
and and his son-in-law says well you ha
he's going to get you killed you need to
arrest him and sir thomas more says
so you're saying that we should just
carve down the law in order to go after
the devil
and roper says yes i'd carve down every
law in england to go after the devil
and sir thomas more says okay and then
when the devil turns around on you and
all the laws are gone where are you
gonna hide
the forests all being flat the idea
being when you get rid of the law when
you decimate the institutions when you
turn the institutions into nothing
in pursuit of something bad what happens
when those institutions
no longer provide a bulwark or a
framework against something truly bad
right what if donald trump is not orange
hitler he's just a guy they don't like
and now all of those institutions have
collapsed and what if something really
bad does happen all the institutions
have lost all of their institutional
credibility
so the left can't acknowledge that
possibility so they have to keep
maintaining that they are always in
pursuit of the devil and if this devil
goes away if donald trump goes away they
will find a new devil in order to
justify their constant disregard and
undermining of their own institutions
right that this is this is what's
happening right now okay so
hence the outsized outrage at donald
trump not just coming out and saying
that joe biden is president-elect
despite the fact that
fact check guys he's not the
president-elect okay just because media
outlets project somebody as presidential
act he's the expected president-elect
you could say that i mean that's fair
he's not the actual president-elect of
the united states until a single state
certifies its vote
legally speaking and i've been informed
by all the various
best fact-checkers that we are supposed
to be as technical and factual as
possible in our claims
so let's just point out he's not
actually president-elect of anything yet
he will be president-elect if the vote
counts hold if the lawsuits don't
overturn those vote counts
okay so donald trump is not in fact
orange hitler for not calling him
president-elect joe biden
or for not starting the transition right
away but the left is fully invested in
this narrative that donald trump is
hitler because this justifies them doing
whatever they can
in order to stop donald trump it
justifies them doing whatever they can
to undermine institutional credibility
of the media of government
and they're doing it full scale okay so
here's a great example jim clyburn
right well-respected democrat probably
one of the leading forces behind joe
biden being president
if it had not been for jim clyburn
stumping for support for joe biden
in south carolina very good shot that
bernie sanders might have been the
nominee
inside the democratic party so jim
clyburn was talking yesterday
on cnn about the about the
unwillingness of donald trump to declare
joe biden the president-elect
and this is pure ridiculous hysteria he
compares
donald trump to adolf hitler now
quick rule of thumb most of the things
that you don't like
have nothing to do with hitler things
can be things that are bad and also have
nothing to do with hitler in fact nearly
everything in your entire life that you
don't like
will not be hitler it turns out that
hitler was basically hitler
and not tons of other hitlers out there
thank god but here was jim clyburn
comparing donald trump to hitler
for not for for not recognizing that joe
biden is president-elect of the united
states
there are many historical problems with
this particular narrative
one one of them is that adolf hitler
actually was
elected in november of 1932 to head the
largest party in the restag and then he
was asked
by the by the president of germany
by by hindenburg who was the acting head
of state to form a coalition government
and then hitler took power and then
liquidated all of his enemies it turns
out donald trump hasn't done any of
those things
but jim clyburn compares him to hitler
anyway because if you call somebody
hitler that means that you can do
whatever the hell you want and lie as
much as you want
i'm beginning to see what happened in
germany back in the 1930s
i never thought that could happen in
this country how do you elect a person
president then all of a sudden give him
the authority
to be dictator that's what we're
teetering on here
that's what hitler did in germany he was
elected chancellor
and then because he uh successfully
discredited
the news media took over the churches
what now uh this is not anything like
what hitler did
in germany like zero zero things are
currently held in common
i'm sorry nobody was talking about hey
hitler you lost an election
would you like a hundred million dollar
book deal and then hitler was like oh
okay no no that that's not what happened
when everything is hitler nothing is
hitler and by the way this is deeply
deeply disgusting on virtually every
level
as a member of the jewish community i
know many people who have tattoos of
numbers in their flesh thanks to hitler
comparing donald trump to hitler because
he won't say that old daughtering joe
biden isn't president-elect yet
spare me it's just self-justificatory
nonsense
i'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you've seen all these stories in
the news right a story where there's a
bad guy
and he inv involves himself in a home
invasion right threaten somebody life
somebody's life and a good guy has to
shoot him and then the good guy
ends up being arrested and now has to
face the legal process well here's the
thing
if you own a gun it's not just enough to
own a gun and one you need to know how
to use it and two
you need to know your legal rights and
have the resources to defend yourself in
case god forbid you actually have to use
a firearm to defend yourself and this is
where the uscca
comes in here's how you can take a
simple powerful journey to firearms and
self-defense confidence it's called the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide from the united
states concealed carry association it is
100 free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you
how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun even if you've got
little kids
and a whole lot more it's 164 pages it
comes with a bonus audio version so you
can listen
whenever you want just text ben to 87
to get started you want to protect your
family if you're a law-abiding citizen
you should have a gun and you should
know how to use it this is where the us
cca comes in you'll get instant access
to that complete concealed carry and
family defense guide from the uscca 100
free
when you text ben to 87 222 and you get
a chance to win a thousand bucks so you
can buy a gun to protect your family
text ben to 87 222 right now
okay so it's not just jim clyburn who is
ramping up the hysteria
it's cnn of course so cnn's jim schudo
he says this could put us at risk for
another 911 if donald trump doesn't
start the transition process immediately
okay let's be very clear about this 911
didn't happen
because the transition was slow in 2000
i know that this is one of the talking
points of the 911 commission the
evidence
on that is extraordinarily scanty 911
happened for a variety of reasons
the fact the transition was kind of slow
meaning it carried on for 37 days in
court before
al gore conceded the election that's not
why 9 11 happened
okay there were institutional barriers
that would have not been alleviated if
the transition had happened faster
bill clinton let al-qaeda basically run
roughshod and fired a couple of
missiles at camelbuts in the middle of
nowhere in order to retaliate for the
uss cole
there are a lot of reasons why 9 11
happened slow transition is
but but now we're we're now grasping at
straws so the reason that it's super
we're like trying to figure out why it's
super bad but the media start with a
proposition the proposition is it's
super bad what trump is doing
then they have to sort of backfill why
it's super bad
what trump is doing they can't say that
it's illegal because it's not illegal
they can't really say it's a threat to
democracy because it's not a threat to
democracy the process is moving forward
and if donald trump
is not president-elect in december when
all the states certify their votes when
the electors vote
then he will leave right everybody
acknowledges this including members of
the trump administration
including the much ballyhooed mike
pompeo secretary of state everybody
knows this
and all this is pretend all this is
protect so they have to backfill so they
say oh well you know if the transition
doesn't happen
fast enough well then that means that
there might be another 911.
okay let's be real about this again joe
biden is not going to formally take
office even if he is president-elect
until january 20th
joe biden himself has said he is not
worried about the transition process
but the media have to spin this thing up
because it justifies all the things
they've been doing for the past several
years to get to trump okay here's jim
sciutto suggesting 911 is on the horizon
if donald trump doesn't immediately
declare joe biden president-elect or
some such
the 911 commission report specifically
cited the shortened transition
after the 2000 election for having an
impact on national security i'm quoting
here
it hampered the new administration in
identifying recruiting
clear clearing and obtaining senate
confirmation of key appointees
the fact is we have experience for how
shortened transitions make a difference
in national security
why are we hearing from republicans
about that granting that potential
danger
i'm sorry this is the the ramped up
hysteria it's because the media are
invested and they can't get uninvested
okay meanwhile
the process continues to move forward
georgia yesterday announced they would
do a full hand recount
of the of all the votes now the
secretary of state of georgia
who is now i will say it's hilarious
that brian kemp right who was the
secretary of state of georgia
when the stacey abrams race happened he
was accused of voter suppression and all
this now democrats are like the georgia
system of voting it's fine
it's fine it's good everything is good
in georgia okay
i tend to agree i don't see tons of
evidence that there's huge swaths of
voter fraud or that a recount is going
to change the results in georgia i just
don't see the evidence
of that presented to the extent it would
be necessary to overturn a 12 000 vote
gap
in georgia but georgia yesterday
announced a full hand recount so the
process is moving forward guys and there
will be an outcome so cool your jets for
five seconds
we'll then move to the risk limiting
audit or rla
at 1 pm today i will make the official
designation of which race will be the
subject of the rla
at that time i will designate that the
roa
will be the presidential race with the
margin being so close
it will require a full by-hand recount
in each county this will help build
confidence
it will be an audit a recount and a
re-canvas
all at once okay so first of all for
trump to win
he would have to then win the recount
then he would have to overturn the
result in arizona then he would have to
overturn the result in pennsylvania
right all of those things would be
necessary in order for trump to win so
there's a very heavy burden here but the
process
again is moving forward georgia's
secretary of state says listen i have a
job to do my integrity matters and i'm
not going to
yeah i'm not going to simply allow voter
fraud to be the thing in georgia
are you worried mr secretary you could
be next
if you say something that the president
doesn't like he doesn't like the fact
that the people of georgia have spoken
and he's losing right now by more than
14 000 votes
i have my job to do and i'll follow it
faithfully
i think that integrity still matters
okay so here is the bottom line
the process will move forward the states
will certify their votes
there are allegations out there kaylee
mcinanny has put out allegations
in michigan of a wide variety of efforts
to affect the election
voter fraud voter irregularities in a
country of 150 million people
you would assume than any process
involving that many people 150 million
voters you would assume that there was
there was some voter fraud and voter
regularity the question is does it meet
the legal burden of overturning an
election the answer is probably no but
that's why we have a process
and that's why it's going to be carried
forward and no this is not hitler and
yes there is a legal process
and everybody calms down but this goes
to a deeper and broader point
okay while everybody in the world on the
right particularly is worried about
the the rigging of the supposed rigging
or stealing of the election
via voter fraud or voter irregularities
the evidence of that is is scanty the
idea that that
the entire election was rigged the
entire the
again there are a bunch of holes in this
particular theory one of the holes in
that particular theory
is that republicans all over the country
seem to outperform president trump in
battleground states
right that just happens to be the
statistical case it also happens to be
that if you're going to rig the election
across the country you probably wouldn't
want the republicans to pick up
somewhere from 10 to 17 seats
in the house as well as hold the senate
right if you're gonna rig this thing
then you rig it
okay but even assuming that that process
is going to play forward
it is still true and i think much more
importantly for the future of the
country
it is still true that the media rigged
the election
i don't mean that they formally went in
and changed vote totals i don't mean
that the media went in and stole the
election by pulling levers i don't mean
any of that what i mean
is that the media make it nearly
impossible nearly impossible
for a republican presidential candidate
to win and the reason
that that is obviously true is because
they themselves are just the apparatus
of the democratic party
there are a wide variety of ways in
which this election was pre-set in terms
of narratives
by your organs of informational
dissemination we're going to get to that
in just a minute because that really is
the threat to the future of us living in
the same republic
a lot of people have talked about the
fact that we seem to be living in two
different realities
we are living in two different realities
because the media live in their bubble
and they refuse to allow any information
outside of that bubble to penetrate
that's a dangerous thing it's a really
really dangerous thing
because if we're living in two separate
realities it's gonna be very difficult
for us to occupy the same country
we're seeing those two separate
realities play out right now people on
the right are saying we should
investigate every claim of voter fraud
and voter irregularity
and members of the media are saying
there is no voter fraud and no voter
irregularity
okay which is crazy there is voter fraud
and there is voter irregularity
now you can say as i have said that i
don't see the full-scale evidence that
voter fraud and voter irregularity make
up the margins of victory
for joe biden in some of these states
right i think that that is an accurate
take but the media aren't saying that
the media immediately go to
if you even distribute information
surrounding voter fraud or voter
irregularity
that has to be stopped because they have
created an anodyne bubble and they live
inside that ending bubble and no
information
is allowed to penetrate that bubble and
because it's not just that that bubble
exists for them
it's because they then expand that
bubble outward to encompass everybody
who simply wants information
this rigs elections okay this rigs how
people think about politics it separates
the american public's
the american public mind into two that
creates a schizophrenic american public
and that's where we are right now we're
gonna get into all the ways that the
media
are really the factor behind the quote
unquote rigging of the 2020 election
we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that
if you ever get malware on your computer
it's just it's just horrifying
right pcmatic it's a next generation
antivirus designed to stop modern
threats like ransomware
independent testing from a vtest just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic however blocks annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing and makes your computer faster
and more reliable even after years of
use
and protect all sorts of devices pcmatic
will protect your windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets and pcmatic is just
50 bucks for 5 devices for 1 year with a
full 30 day money back guarantee if you
act now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase of an annual license
if you're not protecting yourself
against malware or ransomware it's all
fun and games until you actually get one
of these things it is just a pain in the
butt can wreck
your life for weeks on end if you get
malware or ransomware protect yourself
right now with pcmatic
to access this offer head on over to
pcmatic.com
again to get that world-class security
that keeps your computer running great
go to pcmatic.com
that is pcmatic.com ben okay so let's
talk about
who actually rigged the 2020
presidential election and the answer is
your media right your beloved
establishment
journalistic bettors they rigged this
thing in a variety of ways so the first
way
is they just silenced conservatives in
the lead-up to the election
we saw this right we could tell this was
happening on facebook for example
on my personal facebook page for example
you could see the reach on my personal
facebook page
it was like a big it was like a big
giant godzilla foot came down and just
crushed the reach
and you could see it happening in real
time it was not as though it was an
organic
change in the nature of our facebook
reach in the lead up to the election
it was that somebody flipped the switch
and suddenly fewer people were able to
see our posts
why who could have done that and why
would they have done that and the answer
is very obvious
the social media bros decided they did
not want dissemination of information
they didn't like the most obvious
example of this
was of course the entire hunter biden
story you'll recall that the new york
post reported
that hunter biden had a laptop and that
laptop had texts and messages
that made one suspicious that perhaps
joe biden knew more than he was telling
about hunter biden's corrupt business
associations abroad and use of the biden
family name
and this was just crushed from top down
by twitter it was crushed from top down
by facebook facebook announced before
there was even a fact check that they
were going to crush
the dissemination of the information and
then the tech bros just announced you
know what it's really not our fault i
mean
i mean sure we shouldn't have quashed
that story but we don't affect elections
jack dorsey testified in front of
congress said we don't affect elections
that's not what we do
does twitter have the ability to
influence elections
no you don't believe twitter has any
ability to influence elections
no we are one part of a spectrum of
communication challenges that people
have
so you're testifying to this committee
right now that that twitter when it
silences people when it censors people
when it blocks political speech
that has no impact on elections people
people have choice of other
communication channels okay
woke rasputin jack dorsey then admitted
that the suppression of the
new york post story was purely political
he said there's no evidence that it was
disinformation but we called it
disinformation we suggest that it was
hacked materials
you guys distributed like everything
regarding trump's tax returns
and it was very obvious what what
twitter was doing in the rough to the
election here
did anyone have any any information
whatsoever they're not authentic or that
they are russian disinformation
mr darcy we we don't you know
so so why would why would you censor it
why did you prevent that from
being disseminated on your platform that
is supposed to be
for the free expression of ideas and
particularly true ideas
we believe to fill a foul over hacking
materials policy
okay so again the twitter decided what
it wanted you to see facebook decided
what it wanted you to see and the left
was cheering this on the entire way
understand that the social media
companies and the press
and the democratic party they are all
part of the same bubble they are all
working together
there's an iron triangle that exists
between the press which play this
outside game where they pretend they're
objective journalists simply holding
social media to account
the woke staffers at these tech
companies who decide that they are going
to push from within
for those tech companies to become the
expositors of left-wing viewpoints and
the democratic party which is providing
the ideological impetus for all of it
that is an iron triangle democratic
party
media social media companies it is an
iron triangle they all work with each
other
that rigs elections okay that has a
massive impact on how people think
right senator ed markey even chided
twitter and facebook for the crime of
putting up
too much information during the election
the big tech business model which puts
profits ahead of people
is a real problem anti-conservative bias
is not a problem the issue is not
that the companies before us today are
taking too many posts down
the issue is that they're leaving too
many dangerous posts
up in fact they're amplifying
harmful content so that it spreads like
wildfire
and tortures our democracy okay this is
not because they're worried about this
information it's because they are
worried about information they don't
want you seeing
get out and they've made this very clear
the most obvious example came out
yesterday kevin roose from the new york
times who's an activist he's a tech
activist masquerading as a journalist
for the new york times
he put out a post saying facebook is
absolutely teeming with right-wing
misinformation right now
these are all among the 10 most engaged
urls on the platform over the last 24
hours
here are the articles that he declared
misinformation one from the daily wire
my site saying
republican in michigan goes from loser
to winner after technical glitch fixed
officials urge confidence in system
okay that happens to be true there is
one from breitbart
a.g william barr authorizes doj to look
into voting irregularities
also true one from bongino.com michigan
legislature holds rare emergency session
to investigate election irregularities
also happens to be true and one from
breitbart.com purdue
lefler call on georgia secretary of
state to resign over election
also happens to be true so in other
words all four of those headlines were
true but kevin rusted not what any of
them distributed
on facebook and then he admitted why he
said for the conservatives who are mad
about this yes it is possible for a
story to be factually accurate
and for it to be part of a
misinformation campaign aimed at
undermining confidence in an election
in other words your media bros they are
not interested
in the truth they are interested in the
narrative and they're going to push the
social media companies into censoring
stories they don't like that are true
that they admit are true in order to
suppress narratives they don't like
you think that has an impact on rigging
elections it absolutely does
it absolutely does and we saw this kind
of model applied
all the way across the board narrative
after narrative for the last four years
that has an impact on how americans
think it divides americans from
americans and it also creates the
impetus for folks on the left to call
everybody on the right
who is privy to facts that the media
will not report conspiracy theorists
that is what you see oh you reap
breitbart you read daily why are you
daily that's cause you're a conspiracy
theorist
no it's that you have shielded yourself
from information that you do not like
and this is why the media went nuts when
kaylee mcinerney said that the
that the left never sees quote-unquote
alternative facts
the idea was not that she was saying
that people don't see bad facts she was
saying there's a whole set of facts you
are not privy to because the media do
not want you to see them we'll get to
more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that when you think of
your future you think of goals and
and dreams but how are you going to
accomplish those well number one you got
to make your resume better you got to
get yourself educated
why not check out ashford university
ashford university's online bachelor's
and master's degree programs
allow you to learn on a convenient and
flexible schedule at ashford expert
faculty teaches you real-world skills
from real world experience and online
classes
built for life's twists and turns you
can learn from home or wherever you feel
comfortable
you can pursue a degree in one of
ashford's 60-plus programs like business
administration
healthcare administration and psychology
with 24 7 access to your classroom daily
support and financial aid available
ashford will give you the tools you need
to go from dreaming to doing
why not get started right now your
bigger future starts today at ashford
university there's no fee to apply or
standardized testing required to enroll
go make your resume better go learn a
new skill set especially in today's
competitive
job market you want to stand out from
everybody else go to ashford.edu slash
ben that is ashford.edu
ashford.edu and no fee to apply
standardized testing is not required to
enroll not all programs available in all
states
ashford.edu ben to get started okay
so that broad model right that iron
triangle that i've been discussing
between democrats and the media and
social media
that broad model has been applied to
nearly every major narrative of the last
four years which of course is going to
shift dramatically how people think
about an election the true rigors of the
election as i keep saying are the
members of the establishment media
and their and their friends in the
social media space who have decided that
the only
the only outlets that are quote unquote
credible are the outlets they like
so here is a perfect example you have
been told that
donald trump is solely and completely
responsible for 200 000 deaths in the
united states from covet
right joe biden said this openly during
the during the debate which is a
disgusting thing to say
we've seen hundreds of thousands of
people die across europe we've seen over
a million people
die globally donald trump is not
president of
of france he's not the prime minister of
italy he's not the prime minister of the
uk
he's not the prime minister of germany
or the chancellor of germany he's not
any of those things
and yet according to joe biden if it
were not for donald trump
hundreds of thousands of people would
literally be alive today this is the
democratic party talking point you'll
see how it filters directly through the
media
and then social media suppresses any
message that is contrary to this here is
here's joe biden 220 000
americans dead if you hear nothing else
i say tonight
hear this anyone is responsible for not
taking control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america okay and biden kept doubling
down on this throughout the campaign
this was maybe his main closing pitch
on the campaign trail was donald trump
is a giant
mismatic orange blob lingering over the
land and causing you to die of covet
here he was again this is just before
the election
if the president had done his job had
done his job from the beginning
all the people would still be alive all
the people
i'm not making this up just look at the
data look at the data
okay where's the fact check from
anderson cooper he's standing right
there on stage with joe biden
no fact check forth coming from anderson
cooper in fact this message
is mirrored over and over and over by
members of the media so obviously you
get keith olbermann who's a wild member
of the media
suggesting that donald trump should get
the death penalty because he's
responsible for 200 000 deaths
i'm tired of the thought that we're now
going to repeat the months of march and
april in this country
a country that should have learned
something but which in large part has
been
authorized to wallow and die in its own
stupidity
because of one man one dumb bastard
one selfish son of a one real life major
french
attacking the only hope we have the
science
and insisting science is wrong and
fouchy is an idiot and only i can save
you and insisting
you can do whatever you want then the
disease affects almost nobody
donald trump should be on trial for 220
000 murders death penalty for each count
i mean okay so that's the insane version
the less insane version is is
chris cuomo on on cnn right talking
about
how you should be afraid of covid and it
can kill you right he did this whole
routine after having hosted
his brother andrew cuomo the governor of
new york and holding up a giant
nasal swab and and all of that right the
members of the media
were fully complicit in this particular
argument right donald trump had
completely botched the coveted response
every death was on
donald trump right and and if you said
well
i don't see an alternative strategy you
were bad so cnn's brianna keeler
she said there are 220 000 reasons to
talk about covet you know trump had said
we're talking
about kovit too much and the reason he
said that is because you've not provided
any alternative strategy
and so naturally have cnn saying no no
we have to talk about it every day all
the time
because trump just wants to ignore it
there are 220 hundred seventeen reasons
to talk about coronavirus there are
nearly sixty thousand cases per day in
the u.s in rising
the person whose response has failed on
most objective
measures is not fixing his government's
approach to the crisis
instead he's suggesting we just ignore
it the president doesn't even regularly
acknowledge the huge
loss of life that we've experienced here
in the last nine months
in fact he has instead questioned
whether that horrifying number is
accurate
220 000 dead right again keep repeating
the number and suggesting that it's all
trump's fault
this was the media's narrative and then
you had social media that was actively
suppressing
any counter information so for example
if you said anything that was contrary
to who guidelines then youtube would
actually ding you
or you get a facebook fact check if you
said okay you know the who was kind of
wrong about
masks in the first place and the who was
wrong about lockdowns in the first place
and now they reverse themselves then it
was how
you know you're not allowed to put that
up on social media well ding you will
suppress the content
again the idea here is that only the
party line could be repeated on any of
this
and you don't have to downplay covid or
pretend that covet is not dangerous in
order to get dinged for that sort of
thing
there was a narrative the narrative was
that trump failed and everybody else
succeeded and if you cut against that
narrative there was a good shot social
media was going to find a way
to ding you and that narrative had a lot
of traction
hey how about the narrative that trump
was a threat to democracy for four long
years
four long years all we heard from the
media is that trump was not just an
orange hilarian figure
donald trump was a stand-in for vladimir
putin he was a traitor he had sold out
the united states to vladimir putin
right trump had participated with the
russians in stealing the election
i hear a bunch of members of the media
talking about russian collusion which as
it turns out there is no evidence of
breaking news president trump off the
rails it was the beginning of the end
today
the beginning of the end breaking news
tonight new bombshell this is the
beginning of the end
the beginning of the end the walls are
closing in the walls closing in the
walls closing in
it's over the walls closing in the walls
closing in this is going to be the
achilles hill breaking news tonight i
expect trump to depart this week will be
the watershed week trump is in big
trouble
trump's in a lot of trouble it's a sign
of a terrified old man who feels the
walls
closing in the walls are increasingly
closing in on him
tonight the walls are closing in today
changed everything that's a creation of
a narrative right there i mean
a billion a billion a billion members of
the media saying
that russian collusion was at hand we
were gonna find out
trump was a traitor and then of course
nothing ever materialized on that
okay again the narrative is trump was a
threat to democracy and it was universal
it was a tsunami a wave
right he was a threat to democracy it
was promoted by your media
i mean every twitter trend was directed
toward this end for several years
okay every cnn breaking news update
which was not a breaking news update for
several years every time i was in the
gym it'd be wolf blitzer announcing a
breaking news update
about how trump was a what was in
putin's pocket and then it turns out
none of it was true
right the media did the same thing with
white supremacy they suggested that
donald trump was a was a white
supremacist
he was not just a racist he was a he was
in even worse form of a racist he was a
white supremacist
which of course they never explained the
difference they say he's a white
supremacist he's a terrible terrible bad
man
he's forwarding white supremacy they
lied overtly about this they ignored the
fact that trump repeatedly condemned
white supremacy
and they just kept saying this over and
over and over right trump trump is a uh
trump's a white supremacist over and
over and over this was the narrative
threat to democracy donald trump
can i just say one thing so of course he
doesn't denounce white supremacy
sonny because he is a white supremacist
americans have to decide whether they
want a white supremacist
in the white house we've never had it
before maybe we didn't know we had it
but we
certainly know we have it now this
translated over into the supposedly
objective media coverage john roberts on
fox pestering haley mcinney to have
her condem white supremacy even though
trump had already done it and then
refusing to accept yes for an answer
as the person who speaks for the
president does the president
denounce white supremacism and groups
that espouse it
in all their forms this has been
answered yesterday by the president
himself the day before by the president
himself on the debate stage the
president was asked this he said sure
three times
yesterday he was point blank blank asked
do you
uh denounce white supremacy and he said
i've always denounced any form of that
i can go back and read for you in august
2019 and one voice our nation must
condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy in august of
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the kkk neo-nazis
white supremacists and other hate groups
i have an entire list of these quotes
that i can go through with you
he is condemned why is currency more
than any president in modern history
just to clear it up this morning can you
naming it make a declarative statement
that you deny that the president
announces
i just did i mean the media just refused
to accept the answer because of course
they've got a narrative
to promulgate they have a narrative to
promote right this tsunami effect you
get in the media this echo chamber
effect
this feeling that because the message is
bouncing around at you from 17 different
messages and you're not hearing counter
messages because they are suppressed
okay that is in effect an intellectual
and philosophical rigging of the
election
okay we're going to get to more of this
in just a second because the the final
theme here
is that trump is a threat to democracy
right and this was the media pushing
this thing hard and they continue to
push this thing hard which brings us
back to jim clyburn suggesting that
trump is hitler for not
for not acknowledging joe biden as
president-elect but this has been an
ongoing theme with again that iron
triangle social media and media
and the democratic party the message
starts at the democratic party it is
amplified by the media and then the
media browbeat social media and
suppressing any counter messages
right that is the iron triangle and the
democrats browbeat social media into
listening to them with threats
that they're gonna break up social media
or regulate social media if social media
don't become
another partisan outlet on their behalf
that is the way this works we'll get to
more of that and then
and then they claim that trump is the
threat to democracy we'll get some more
of that in just one second first
for those of you who are wondering where
i get all of this
vigor and energy and virility i know
that that has crossed your mind before
let me tell you it's black rifle coffee
black rifle coffee is
unbelievably good stuff so since i have
three young children and they wake me up
in all hours of the night then i have to
work
all day the next day i become addicted
to black rifle coffee it is
excellent excellent stuff black rifle
coffee company ceo and founder evan
hafer
started the business after over 20 years
in the us army as an infantryman
special forces soldier and cia
contractor i haven't found black rifle
in 2014
along with former army ranger matt best
as the combination of two passions
developing premium fresh roasted coffee
and honoring and supporting those who
serve on the front lines
black rifle has donated over 45 000
pounds of coffee or over 1 million cups
of coffee to soldiers deployed overseas
law enforcement officers wildland
firefighters on the west coast
and medical workers during the coven 19
response just in 2020
alone for every coffee purchase you make
throughout november black rifle coffee
will send a bag of their limited edition
holiday roast to a service member
currently deployed overseas to be
delivered
by christmas morning being founded and
operated by vets the team at black rifle
knows what a quality cup of coffee means
to active duty troops spending the
holidays away from home so
you're doing something awesome every
time you buy black rifle coffee not only
for yourself because the coffee is
delicious
but also because you're helping out the
troops because black rifle is going to
be sending a bag of their limited
edition holiday roast to a service
member
currently deployed overseas for every
coffee purchase you make throughout
november so
if you want to support the cause head on
over to blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro today to get 20 off coffee
apparel and gear as well as 20
off your first month of the coffee club
that's blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro for 20 off coffee apparel and
gear and 20
off your first month of the coffee club
blackriflecoffee.com
go check them out right now they are
awesome folks and their coffee also
happens to be
absolutely delicious all right we're
going to get to more
of the media the establishment media's
rigging of the election but
if you are not already disgusted by the
legacy media you certainly should be now
the media preemptively called the
election in favor of joe biden and now
they're saying that we should not even
investigate voter fraud or voter
irregularity claims and that you're a
bad evil bad dictator bad person
if you don't acknowledge that joe biden
is president-elect despite the fact that
not a single state has certified its
vote yet
just because cnn and fox news declare
something does not make it true
it means very often they are pushing a
narrative that benefits them not only
that the media has already shifted from
demonizing president trump
as orange hitler and demonizing his
supporters as brown shirts to flattering
joe biden and kamala harris
and putting them on magazine covers and
talking about how they're the saviors of
the country and your little daughter is
going to emulate kamala harris and joe
biden is
is going to restore our souls the dust
hasn't even settled we're already
reading stories about joe's rescue dogs
and jill's stunning wardrobe
if you're sick of the media like just
sick of them replace your cable and your
new subscription head on over to
dailywire.com
we have big plans for the next four
years our goal is to replace the media
that is our goal
candace owens new york times
best-selling author founder of the
blexit foundation is joining daily wire
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us early next year i couldn't be
more excited about it
we're also going to be launching an
entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team we're
going to be building partnerships with
like-minded content creators like
prageru their entire show library will
be available to dailywire.com members by
the end of the year
we're going after the legacy media we're
going after them hard we're going to do
it by building a huge
membership base of supporters like you
so when you subscribe
over at daily wire you're not just
helping us out and making sure we can
bring you the information you want you
are actively fighting the establishment
media that helps rig this election right
now
just to show you that we're serious we
are offering 25 off all memberships with
code election
over at dailywire.com subscribe members
get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show and exclusive reader's
past content available only to daily
wire members
if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for live stream
discussions with our hosts and an
amazing online community
you guessed not one but two leftist
years tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products so
remember
that is 25 off all memberships with code
election over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
daily wire you will not regret it
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
and we're talking here about the the
actual rigging of the election meaning
changing people's minds via suppression
of information and propagandizing
efforts
the media are responsible for this i
know everybody right now is focusing in
on voter irregularities and voter fraud
and all those cases will be investigated
all of those cases
we have officials whose literal job it
is to investigate all of those cases
over the doj we have republican
secretaries of state in many of the
states that are currently being battled
over
we have a lot of republican officials in
various counties whose job it is to
oversee these elections those will all
be investigated
long term i'm significantly more worried
about the rigging of elections by our
media which are with five to ten points
in every election
for democrats because if people actually
were able to see alternative sources of
information people actually
were able to view alternative
information in serious numbers
if they were not being suppressed if the
media were not lying if the media hired
one
trump supporter it would be a radical
sea change in how politics was viewed
inside the united states because the
final narrative was pushed by the media
and what i'm calling right now is this
media iron triangle this informational
iron triangle the media democratic party
social media right that is the triangle
right the the final narrative that was
pushed really really hard is of course
the biggest one which is that trump is
himself a threat to democracy
right that not not only is he a threat
to democracy because of russian
collusion and
and he personally is a russian tool and
not only is he
a white supremacist but also that he is
literally going to threaten your vote so
all the same people today this is the
part that's so ironic and so hilarious
and sad the entire media infrastructure
that right now is declaring that the
vote
is clean and legal and good five
minutes ago was claiming that the vote
was going to be overtly thwarted by
donald trump
there's gonna be widespread voter
suppression in places like georgia there
was going to be an inability to vote all
across the country
donald trump was going to go personally
set fire to your mailbox so you couldn't
send in a mail in ballot
he was going to dismantle voting
machines donald trump was going to make
sure he couldn't vote democracy itself
would be thwarted and this is how you
get chris hayes saying that donald trump
is now plotting a coup
right this is this he he said this right
donald trump's plan to steal the
election
remember these are the same people who
right now are saying that because donald
trump is not conceding the election but
he's also not sticking around
if they're actual if the actual election
results are certified these are the same
people
saying that's bad that's a coup they
were saying five seconds ago that trump
was planning to steal the election they
were saying this months in advance and
he was going to do so because he was a
threat to democracy here's chris hayes
who's become just
a hysterical screed writer on twitter
if you're talking to a person and you
ask them to commit to behave peacefully
and they
refuse they're threatening violence
right
what the president is doing here is the
most explicit that he has been about his
plans for this election he's
plotting in open in public repeatedly a
coup
to steal the election and hold on to
power again
it all sounds crazy to say it is what we
are seeing those are the plain facts as
assembled before us
it's not a behind-the-scenes type of
thing it's happening
in public in plain view okay this is all
democrats we're talking about in the
lead up to the election trump was gonna
thwart the election
he was going to not allow a free and
fair election to even take place barack
obama at the dnc
said the administration is going to tear
down democracy this demagogue said this
while standing in front of a wall
plastered with the words of the
constitution of the united states here's
barack obama
you're the missing ingredient the ones
who will decide whether or not
america becomes the country that fully
lives up
to its creed that work will continue
long after this election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election this
administration has shown it will tear
our democracy down if that's what it
takes for them to win
so we have to get busy building it up
it's a coup it's a coup it's a coo it's
a coup right they were saying this for
months in advance they're gonna pervert
the election
this is how they're getting their early
votes out right they're saying you need
to vote early and you need to vote right
now because if you don't donald trump is
gonna come to your house with a bat and
he's gonna smack you on the grill
and then he's gonna steal your vote fill
it out donald trump and send it in right
this was the narrative
it was pushed by the media it was pushed
by democratic parties and then and then
it was
pushed by by social media now the same
social media who are saying you can't
talk about voter fraud or voter
irregularity today they're suppressing
those stories because it undermines
confidence in the election
five seconds ago we're perfectly happy
disseminating all sorts of bull crap
about how the post office of the united
states was going to thwart the election
and how the republicans were going to
defund the post office in order to
prevent your mail and vote from being
counted as it turns out
literally tens of millions 10 like an
unprecedented num unprecedented number
of people voted mail in and all their
votes were counted
it doesn't matter right way back when it
was the post office the post office
right it was all the undermining of
democracy
this is how elections get rigged okay
again not in the hard sense that
the members of the media are out there
changing votes but in the soft sense
that they are are rigging the
informational sources that you are
capable of seeing
right this was the democratic narrative
and don't let them rewrite the history
right barack obama suggested that donald
trump was trying to discourage voting
right there's something like this is
this is conspiratorial thinking
we're told now that it's a conspiracy
theory to talk about voter fraud or
voter irregularity even if you say like
i do that i don't think that the voter
fraud and voter irregularity numbers are
going to come in
where trump needs them to be in order to
overturn the results of the apparent
results of the election
right even that is considered
conspiratorial thinking but barack obama
the entire democratic party the entire
media infrastructure suggested
that the election was going to be
perverted and thwarted by the will of
one orange hitler donald trump here's
barack obama way back when
what we've seen in a way that is unique
to modern political history
is a presence who's explicit in trying
to discourage people from voting
what we've never seen before is
a president say i'm going to try to
actively kneecap
the postal service to encourage voting
and i
will be explicit about the reason i'm
doing it yeah that's sort of unheard of
okay well um no actually the democracy
was not boarded it was never in danger
of being forwarded but again that didn't
stop anybody who's rachel maddow crying
about the postal service right
they're taking away the post office
boxes we saw actual photos being
disseminated
by left-wing media figures of post
office boxes being removed
yes because nobody uses the mail anymore
idiots we've dismantled hundreds of
thousands of post office boxes since the
beginning
of the of the 21st century but again
this was this was the big story in the
media
don't for don't let them rewrite the
history where we now pretend they were
objective all the way through this they
were not even close to objective nor did
they pretend to be now rachel maddow
isn't not an objective news figure
but again rachel maddow is a stand-in
here for so many members of the news who
decided they were going to treat their
own objectivity as a dispensable item
it's how we get our letters it's how we
get our ballots now because of the covid
crisis
it's the freaking fracking mail we need
it but this is a fight against a thing
that americans
actually and quite broadly love
and respect and don't want to go away
this is the kind of fight that most
americans have a side they want to be on
and it is not the side that is stealing
the mailboxes and telling us that
yeah it doesn't thank you i don't think
it's going to work out for you to get
your ballot in on time
you know getting weepy over the
mailboxes right and this one again
some of these stories i'm sure your
grandmother saw and some of these
stories i'm sure your grandmother did
not see
i am sure that millions of people never
saw the hunter biden stories but
learned that donald trump was going to
steal your mailbox i am sure
that there are millions of people across
the country in fact everybody across the
country
who heard that donald trump was a white
supremacist and a russian stand-in
but never heard a single word about joe
biden and kamala harris
like at all they didn't even exist in
this campaign joe biden spent the entire
campaign hiding in a basement and the
media asked him questions like what
flavor of ice cream are you ordering
so when we talk about the ringing of an
election there are two ways you can rig
an election one
is like the old-fashioned castro stalin
way of rigging an election where you
hold an election you win 99 of the vote
because you are the one counting the
vote
right then there is the media's way of
rigging an election which is to add five
to ten points to every democratic vote
total by simply suppressing information
they don't want you to see
and promoting narratives that they do
want you to see
the establishment media blew out their
credibility in this election cycle they
blew it out
since 2016 i don't think they should
have had a lot of credibility in the
first place but
presumably hundreds of millions of
americans think they do
for worse not for better they blew out
that credibility
everybody should take note of that
moving forward now among the things that
the media refused to cover is of course
what joe biden plans to do once
all of this is over if joe biden is in
fact legally made the president's elect
of the united states not just projected
legally made the president's elect of
the united states what's going to happen
next now we were
shielded from the actual knowledge of
those things
right we were shielded from knowledge of
those things because the media didn't
want you to talk about any of that and
in fact if you talked about what joe
biden supported they would fact check
you
in ways that were completely false they
would just issue these false fact checks
i mean this is another way in which the
media perverted the narrative here
they have these fact-checking
organizations they outsource all of
their
all their dirty work to the
fact-checking organizations the
fact-checking organizations then perform
fact checks on implications
and then social media quash stories
based on it so perfect example
during the election cycle there was an
ad that was taken out against gary
peters who's a michigan senatorial
candidate who defeated
john james in the uh in the vote count
in michigan
okay gary peters supports the so-called
equality act
which is a congressional act that
essentially makes it possible for
biological boys to race against
biological girls there was an ad that
was taken out by super pac against gary
peters pointing out that this is wildly
out of step with what most americans and
michiganders
feel about who should be able to race in
athletics and what it would do to
women's athletics if men were allowed to
compete inside
women's athletics facebook took down the
ad
why because it was fact checked the fact
check didn't say the ad was false
the fact check said that it was a little
bit over broad or that it drew
implications that may not be true but it
was really more opinion than it was fact
so there was really no way to fact check
it that didn't matter that was enough
facebook simply suppressed the ad
we saw facebook suppress an ad from the
trump campaign saying that joe biden was
going to raise your taxes joe biden is
going to raise your taxes
right joe biden says he's not going to
raise taxes on anybody of making above
400 000
but he's raising the corporate tax rate
which gets passed down to you he's
raising the payroll tax that gets passed
down to you
right in fact most kind of bipartisan
and nonpartisan economic studies suggest
that joe biden is planning to raise
taxes on a vast variety of people
because if you get rid of the trump tax
cuts as it turns out you are raising
taxes on a huge majority of the american
public
hey that that ad was fact checked as
false and then facebook removed it
okay so the fact checkers play this game
and then the social media companies
simply suppress information on the basis
of false
fact checks it's horrifying the fact
checking
sites are themselves members of the
praetorian guard
of the democratic party praetorian guard
and they guarded you from having to ask
questions about what exactly joe biden
was going to do every time
donald trump said joe biden supports the
green new deal and then pointed out that
aoc's version of the green new deal
is a radical document filled with wild
garbage the media were like well he
doesn't really support that
every time donald trump or mike pence
said that joe biden stands with defund
the police
the media would say well he's overtly
said he's not for defund the police and
then
the trump campaign would bring out the
clip of him saying that he's interested
in shifting funding from the police to
elsewhere this is technically a
defunding of the police
if i say to you i'm going to shift your
salary dollars from you to bob
am i defunding you yes yes i am
okay but apparently that was fact check
falls and so those messages got
suppressed so we never found out exactly
what it was that joe biden was going to
do it was all about trump
it was all about trump that is how you
rig an election you make the person on
the other side of the election a
complete non-entity
even today joe biden is a complete
non-entity
all right so with that said now we are
finding out what joe biden and the
democratic party plan to do
if indeed they are initiated into power
so joe biden has now announced his first
plans
his first plans are he's gonna open the
borders according to cbs news
after biden is sworn in in january his
administration will move to fully
restore
an obama era program that shields 640
000 undocumented immigrants who are
brought to the us's children from
deportation
halting mr trump's unsuccessful efforts
to end it people familiar with the plans
told cbs news
the incoming administration also intends
to rescind trump's travel and
immigration restrictions on 13
mostly african or predominantly muslim
countries okay so already you can see
the media bias here number one
the original daca program put in place
by barack obama was unconstitutional he
had no power to do it he admitted dozens
of times
he could not through executive action
simply refused to enforce immigration
law he did it anyway
then they found some democrat judges to
suggest that
donald trump could not undo an executive
action done by barack obama now
it's going to be joe biden coming in and
redoing the illegal thing
that barack obama did also the the
way that the media characterized trump's
travel ban as a muslim ban
there are countries on the list that are
not muslim so instead they just
they just broaden the description right
his travel and immigration restrictions
on
13 mostly african or predominantly
muslim countries right the implication
being the trump is a xenophobe this has
nothing to do with our inability to vet
people coming into the country
from countries that actually have no
functional government so we have no idea
who's coming into the country
this means that joe biden is good right
he's not xenophobic right this is the
narrative
also joe biden will look to implement a
100-day freeze on deportations a
complete
freeze on deportations now that's
ridiculous we know
that there are thousands of criminals in
the united states like in our jails who
we should deport
we know this this is a fact there are
criminals in the united states
who should be deported he's going to
issue an entire
freeze a moratorium on deportations now
how do you think that would look if that
had been the headline
for six months instead of bullcrap
claims about the postmaster general
how would it look if it were joe biden
on entering office is going to stop all
deportations
including of criminals obama-era memos
that prioritize the deportation of
immigrants with criminal convictions
recent border crossers and those who
entered the country illegally more than
once were scrapped in 2017 by trump
so no unauthorized immigrant would be
exempted from being arrested and removed
from
the country a source familiar with
biden's plan said new guidance would be
designed to curb
so-called collateral arrests which are
apprehensions of immigrants who are not
the target
of us immigrations and customs
enforcement but are nevertheless taken
into custody because they are in the
country without legal status so he's
going to decriminalize basically being
in the country illegally
you're not going to be deported unless
you've committed an overt second crime
so he's basically just going to undo all
of trump's executive actions
on illegal immigration also biden has
pledged to discontinue the trump
administration's policy
of requiring non-mexican migrants to
wait in mexico for the duration of their
u.s asylum cases
now that is a simple and reasonable
request
right is that if you are attempting to
immigrate into the united states you
don't have to set foot on american soil
in order for you to apply for asylum
because what happens there is you apply
for asylum
while the application goes forward you
just disappear into the interior of the
united states so trump made a deal
with central american and latin american
countries that immigrants
could wait in mexico in order so that
they could have their asylum process
before entering the united states and
then just kind of
getting lost in the shuffle biden's
gonna undo that
a source familiar with the biden's team
planning said the incoming
administration will withdraw from the
three bilateral agreements trump
brokered with guatemala el salvador and
honduras that allowed the us to send
rejected asylum seekers to those
countries and have them seek refuge
there so if you enjoyed those caravans
that we were getting
in the obama era and the early trump era
get ready those are coming back we're
gonna get hundreds of thousands of
people marching to the us border and
declaring that they are eligible for
asylum even though they have no actual
asylum claims and then housed and kept
in the united states until those asylum
claims are adjudicated by which point
many of those people will disappeared
into the interior of the united states
so if you enjoyed that
then get ready we're gonna get more of
that we didn't hear any discussion of
that during the campaign
it was all about orange hitler because
again for the one thousandth time the
media break this thing
okay they're also going to apparently
get rid
of uh they're gonna scrap trump's
pandemic era limit
on immigration and work visas biden's
campaign promised the former vp will
direct the cdc to review the expulsion's
policy to ensure that people have the
ability to submit their asylum claims
while ensuring we are taking appropriate
covet 19 safety precautions also he's
going to dramatically increase
refugee admissions moving away from the
record low 15 000 spot set by trump and
raising the cap to 125 000.
okay now again i have no problem with
bringing in refugees to the country who
fulfill
all of the requirements we want for
people living in the united states and
becoming american citizens
we're a welcoming open country and i
think it's great that we welcome
refugees particularly from countries
with repressive regimes and people are
coming in seeking freedom but
you do have to vet people who are coming
into the country that's kind of an
important thing
biden's not going to do any of that okay
so he's undoing basically all of the
immigration policies including ones that
should have wide bipartisan approval
like wait in another country to see if
your asylum
claim is adjudicated properly in the
united states so that that is biden's
first step
meanwhile inside the democratic party
the battle over the future of the
democratic party continues to rage
and i think we all know who's going to
win this battle it's not going to be the
mainstream liberal democrats it's not
going to be conor lamb or abigail
spanberger the woke are going to win
and the woke are going to win because
there is a systemic flaw inside liberal
thinking
so a lot of liberals they don't actually
agree with tearing down the system
they don't agree with tearing down the
system but they've been making the
argument for decades that the system is
itself perverse
that the system itself is rooted in
hierarchies of power which is why we
need to use the system in order to
engage in redistributionism
and we need to curb the rights of some
in order to guarantee
privileges for others and along come
this group of wokesters and they say
okay you guys keep
nibbling around the edges but that's
just because you want to stay in power
right what you need to do is turn over
power to us and we need to tear down the
system as a whole
there is no immune system to this inside
the democratic party which is why stacey
abrams now
you know obviously the governor of
georgia besides being governor of
georgia now being hailed as the great
heroine
of georgia because she was involved in a
voter registration drive in georgia
she is continuing to say that democrats
need to stop
moving away from identity politics
doesn't matter that republicans want a
bevy of house seats
came close to taking back a house
majority in a time when no one really
thought they would
are going to maintain the senate
majority in all likelihood stacey abrams
says identity politics is how the
democratic party
moves forward here she was speaking at
an event in washington dc at the center
for american progress
ideas conference for those of us who are
in this coalition of new and engaged
who are in this pursuit of progress we
have to recognize that the internal
threat we face
is a fear of who we are the notion of
identity politics has been peddled for
the last 10 years
and it's been used as a dog whistle to
say that we shouldn't pay too much
attention
to the new voices coming into progress
i would argue that identity politics is
exactly who we are
and it's exactly how we won identity
politics is who they are
and how they won the coalition of the
oppressed rising up to strike down
all of the systems and institutions uh
the quick note that i was gonna make
there is if you actually watch that
video she's speaking in a closed room
wow with lots of people in it see if the
republicans hold a rally
in a closed room with lots of people in
it it's a it's a coveted hotbed if
stacey abrams speaks to the center for
american progress at a dinner where
everybody's sitting around tables and
men are not wearing masks
it's no problem because of course the
virus is woke okay but this is the
future of the democratic party
black lives matter sent a letter to the
leaders of the democratic party saying
we want something for our vote right we
know where this is all going
according to the federalist blm
co-founder patrice cullers sent a letter
to former vice president joe biden and
his vice presidential nominee kamala
harris congratulating them on winning
the presidential election
demanding a meeting to discuss blm's
expectations for their administration
a well-thought-out community-driven
fully resourced agenda that addresses
the particular challenges faced by black
people
must be the priority that is what she
wrote
according to colors a democratic victory
would not have happened without the
resounding support of black people
in short black people won this election
she said noting the group's efforts to
vote and organize
alongside black led organizations around
the nation black lives matter invested
heavily
in this election black people cannot
afford to live through the vitrail of a
trump-like presidency nor through the
indifference of a democrat-controlled
government
that refuses to wrestle with its most
egregious and damnable shame
colors claims that biden and harris who
both ran on a platform mentioning
systemic racism owed it to the movement
to act on their rhetoric and further the
work of black liberation she said we
want something for our vote
we want to be heard we want our agenda
prioritized we issue these expectations
not just because black people are the
most consistent and reliable voters for
democrats but also because black people
are truly living in a crisis in a nation
that was built on our subjugation
right you think the democratic party is
going to turn this down do you joe biden
said
in his quasi-acceptance address he said
black americans stood behind them
and so i'm going to stand behind you
which again if you said that about any
other racial group in america you would
recognize how racist and divisive and
terrible that is
but apparently it's totally okay for joe
biden to say and he's going to be the
guy who stands in for america's
institutions
i think not meanwhile the justice
democrats are preemptively declaring all
of their opponents racists
they sent a letter to the entire
democratic caucus saying quote
conservative democrats
may change the terms and people we blame
and fear year by year but democrats must
take on the republican party's divide
and conquer racism head on
and not demobilize our own base
they say that we cannot abandon the
identity politics
the lesson to be learned from this
election says justice democrats and this
is like aoc
and oh sorry the honorable
representative alexander ocasio-cortez
defresh face
they say the lesson to be learned from
this election cannot and should not be
to lean into racist resentment politics
or back away from the social movements
that push democrats to power
if democrats cower from the national
conversation sparked by the black lives
matter movement
then the only ones left owning this
space will be the gop the democratic
party has long taken the party
the base of its party black voters for
granted we need a democratic party
dedicated to economic and racial justice
we cannot allow billionaires on fox news
to divide and conquer america we must
invest
in all our workers to create good paying
jobs safety and shared prosperity for
all
not just for those on the top right do
you think joe biden's going to stand up
to that
i have questions i ha i think not i
think not
and here's the problem this agenda
really has no end except for political
dominance right the agenda does not have
an endpoint except for tearing away all
of the institutions that apparently
are vestiges of power politics see
for a lot of the marxist theoreticians
in the democratic party and inside
organizations like blm
the basic idea is that society is
structured by hierarchies of power
and the institutions that you treasure
the institutions joe biden claims to
stand for that he claims he wants to
unify around
those institutions were created in order
to perpetuate those hierarchies of power
and it is not sufficient to perpetuate
those hierarchies of power
or to use those hierarchies of power for
redistribution instead they need to be
torn out at the root
do you think joe biden has the ability
to deny these folks that
there is no logical endpoint okay that
is the agenda that is the agenda moving
forward
republicans are gonna need to fight back
against this agenda because you can see
it playing out in georgia
so right now the next step putting aside
the presidential election which will
come out how it comes out
the next step is going to be january 5th
right in early january there's going to
be two special elections in georgia
those two special elections pit
republicans against democrats kelly
lefler
in one race versus raphael warnock who's
a radical
and david perdue sitting senator in
georgia against john ossoff
who has been run one thousand he's sort
of like beta o'rourke except georgia
right all he does
is run for office and lose in georgia
right he lost his race this time around
to david perdue it's just that georgia
has a weird system
where if you don't win a majority of the
vote outright then you have to redo the
race so
david perdue won like 49.8 percent of
the of the vote and uh john ossoff won
47 percent of the vote
doesn't matter they have to do a runoff
again in january and democrats are
pulling out all the stops they're making
very clear what they want here they want
to fundamentally transform the country
you think these are people who are
satisfied with the sort of unity
nibbling around the edges approach of
joe biden i think not john also said
and this democratic senatorial candidate
who uh is is just a socialist in
disguise he said change is coming to
america
right i think that's kind of what we're
afraid of he said the people of our
state have made an extraordinary
statement in these last few weeks
and let's be honest there were some who
doubted us when i got in this race about
14 months ago
i was telling everyone that georgia is
the most competitive state in the
country i know that you all believed me
but there were some who did not
but what we have proven in these last
few weeks the change has come to georgia
change is coming to america and
retirement is coming for senator david
perdue what kind of change
well why don't we examine the other race
raphael warnock
who is protected by the media and will
continue to be protected by the media is
a deeply
deeply radical candidate how radical is
raphael warnock
he praised reverend jeremiah wright's
speeches
has for years been one of the most vocal
defenders of wright's infamous 2003
gd america serbian which compared us
leaders to al qaeda and claimed hiv was
invented by the government as a way to
kill black people as according to the
washington free beacon
according to politico the democratic
candidate is expected to face negative
ads that target his ties to jeremiah
wright
warnock has a long history of
anti-israel extremism lefleur wrote on
twitter that is absolutely true
he gave a speech last like this year
talking about how israel was an
oppressive regime
murdering palestinian innocents
not only that wright came to national
attention in 2008
obviously as the spiritual adviser to
barack obama and then john mccain
because he was a pansy in that election
refused to mention jeremiah wright
anywhere throughout the election even
though he was an ideological mentor
to barack obama warnock is an open
defender of jeremiah wright in 2014 he
praised that gd america sermon in a
speech at the auburn avenue research
library he said quote
you ought to go back and see if you can
find and read as i have the entire
sermon it was a very fine sermon
jeremiah wright was right when he said
the attack on him in a real sense was an
attack on the black church
the message of jeremiah wright was that
public policy has consequences
in 2013 warnock called the rights sermon
a very fine homily
in his 2013 book the divided mind of the
black church
he actually compared jeremiah wright to
the biblical prophet jeremiah
this would be the same jeremiah right
who engaged the us in israel of engaging
in state terrorism and said that
september 11th was america's chickens
coming home to roost and that is that is
raphael warnock
who's running for senate in georgia
right now
okay raphael warnock also it turns out
was implicated he was actually arrested
in 2002 apparently after allegedly
obstructing a police investigation into
suspected child abuse tom cotton the
senator from arkansas tweeted out about
this yesterday he said in 2002
when the police investigated suspected
child abuse at rafael warnock's church
camp for children
warnock was arrested for obstructing the
investigation will the media ask rafael
warnock why he interfered with the
police investigation
according to original reporting at the
time warnock and marc andre wainwright
the assistant minister for youth were
accused of trying to bar a state trooper
from interviewing counselors at the camp
neither warnock nor wainwright was a
suspect in the child abuse investigation
but they interrupted a police interview
of a counselor the ministers interrupted
a police interview of a counselor
wednesday in a room at the camp and
after investigators moved the interview
to a nearby picnic area interfered again
and subsequently tried to prevent a
camper from directing police to another
potential witness
according to charging documents this is
according to the baltimore sun in 2002.
trooper diane berry of the state police
child and sexual assault unit said quote
i've never encountered resistance like
that
at all she pointed out the counselors
were informed they could leave at any
time
they still consented to be interviewed
so this is this is raphael warnock
excellent excellent stuff
this this is who the democrats have
decided to put up as their nominee
okay this is what republicans are going
to have to fight back against
joe biden's administration is not going
to turn these people away joe biden's
administration is going to welcome these
people
joe biden is acting like he's a bulwark
for moderation yeah fat chance
fast chance and republicans know this by
the way kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader
he pointed out yesterday the best way to
uh for republicans to win is just to let
these people talk and he is correct
you the cycle raised more money than any
house republican
ever more than any of your speaker
predecessors
what did you learn and how did you pull
this off well
the best way to raise money is just let
nancy pelosi and aoc talk
so you bring up a relatively junior
member congresswoman
ocasio-cortez why do your people respond
so vociferously to her
well she runs the floor what do you mean
by that
that wing of the party the socialist
wing of the party
they are the new power of the democratic
party
and senator marco rubio made the same
point yesterday he said listen not all
the democrats are socialists but all the
socialists are democrats
okay now that's not totally true there
are a lot of socialists who are not
democrats there are a lot of socialists
in antifa there are a lot of socialists
who don't vote
but it is certainly true that the bulk
of socialists in the united states will
identify more closely with the
democratic party than the republican
party that's for damn sure here was
senator rubio yesterday
there are people in america who work in
places where they are afraid
to put a bumper sticker on their car or
wear a hat because they could get fired
and if you think i'm exaggerating
they're making lists there are people
right now making lists
of people they want to go after members
of congress making lists about people
we're going to go after these people and
destroy their lives
this is lunacy all that reminds me of is
this
it is true to be fair not all democrats
are socialists
but all the socialists are democrats
okay this happens to be true it also
happens to be
the the strongest argument that
republicans are going to have
going forward okay joe biden is a danger
but you never heard that from the media
right joe biden was just a nice old man
who's basically going to restore
normalcy
nope no he absolutely is not by the way
normalc has been completely lost let's
just point this out here
i will i will point to uh one indicator
that i think is is pretty indicative so
there is a new policy in norway
apparently
okay in which norway has now made
biphobic and transphobic speech illegal
according to out magazine by trans and
non-binary folks in norway are
celebrating
a huge win after the country recently
expanded its penal code that previously
only protected
lesbian and gay people from hate speech
to include gender identity and all forms
of sexual orientation
the penal code states those who are
guilty of hate speech face a fine or up
to a year in jail for private comments
and a maximum of three years in jail for
public comments okay so that's a radical
policy that is if you are at home
and you say something you quote
leviticus
in your house the the government of
norway can come and take you out of your
house and put you in jail for a year
so out magazine right the the gay
advocacy magazine in the united states
they tweeted out buy us a one-way ticket
they're into it man they want to live in
a country where people can be prosecuted
for
saying a thing in their own home and
that's how radical the left in the
united states is becoming
it's amazing how fast we went the united
states from you know
what we do in our bedroom is none of
your business too what you say about us
in your bedroom should get you thrown in
jail
pretty incredible transition right it
went from you should tolerate more
people doing what they want in the
privacy of their own home to
if you say something i don't like in the
privacy of your own home i hope they
take you and throw you in jail right now
you wonder why folks in the united
states may be a little wary of the
radical left
because the radical left has no actual
allegiance to institutions and
fundamental principles like freedom of
speech and open discussion
they oppose them and joe biden is not
going to be able work against that
that is why republicans across the
country did much better than expected in
the 2020 elections
and if it were not for the mainstream
media spending 24 hours a day lying
about trump
presumably trump would have won the
election okay so that that is the that
is the ongoing story here and that's
going to be the battle to be left to be
fought
you know that that battle is going to
have to be waged on a media level
because the media will simply hide these
messages from you the media will not
promulgate these messages they will not
give you the truth about this stuff they
will suppress anybody who talks about
this sort of stuff
that is there that is their job because
they are in open competition with other
forms
of informational dissemination they'll
try to hijack all of the platforms of
informational dissemination in order to
prevent you
from seeing information they don't like
and that's what we are all fighting back
against today
all right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam's psy event
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by nico
geneva the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen
you